um epidemic give me numbers AIDS at its
highest the United States
I mean it's continues to be high I don't
have all those numbers out the red here
but I don't have nothing ready I'm not
gonna remember about the cancer
countable the diabetes epidemic
coverable divert everybody they're not
hits they're not
I know we don't agree on a whole lot but
you know we actually have people who are
who are gay transgender who agree with
me more in politics who aren't willing
to come on the show so we always respect
anyone who's willing to come in here and
bang so to speak stand in the pocket Zac
you have been upset on the Twitter with
me before for I mean I transphobic being
anti trans ain't eh tell me what it is
that that that you see is a problem and
in what I say or the floor is yours if
you want to tell conservatives how to
get this right sure well you know
there's a lot of misinformation out
there and we can kind of get into some
of those specifics but the the bottom
line is that as students need help
trans people need help they are one of
the most targeted groups for
discrimination they experienced really
high rates of unemployment and
homelessness and poverty as a result of
that discrimination they denied health
care because of that discrimination and
just how about health care sometimes
doctors are transphobic and refused to
give them health care some of them
because they refuse to like give them
antibiotics for a cold they refused to
give them flu shots when you say denied
health care what do you mean it's
important we frame that in well it can
mean a variety of things it can mean
that they don't have insurance because
they don't have a job and so they just
can't afford health care so they don't
even get to the doctor it could be that
they don't have a doctor in their
community that respects who they are and
so they don't feel comfortable going to
that doctor okay now it's feeling that's
important I wanna make sure we get the
word I want to show you get the language
right here because especially you know
if you've accused me being ignorant on
Twitter that's okay and I respect that
you can say that but that's not accurate
to say being denied health care if they
don't have insurance because I don't
have a job or if they don't feel
comfortable going to a doctor they're
not being denied health care so when you
say denied health care that means a
doctor proactively denying someone
health care all health care solely
because they're trans is that really a
common occurrence it definitely happens
I mean if you look at the the 2011
national transgender discrimination
survey it was just the largest look at
what trans people actually experience
there are certainly people who reported
experiences like that where they they
came out to their doctor as trans and
either received no treatment or didn't
receive the treatment that they need so
in regards to typically a trans
whatever doctor says hey I'll treat you
and everything else but I'm not gonna do
the hormone replacement therapy this is
an issue I'm not gonna touch because the
science isn't in and I don't think it's
good for you is that considered denying
healthcare I think it is because a lot
of the care that they need for the
transition is medically necessary if
they can't achieve mental health
wellness because leave it cementec a
medically hard transition there's no
evidence to suggest that it is well sure
there is no that's some of the missing
information that we can get into if you
want you I mean one of the other right
I've got it right here let me bring this
up because this is important that we can
get into grey matter and we can talk
about you know how the brain works but
I've got this a pretty empirical
analysis here it is not surprising the
influence of sex hormones in the brain
we're not limited to hit the thalamus
but they're all expressed remember so
prior to cross sex hormone treatment a
lot of the studies that I've heard you
tried out and people tried out were
involved with people after they had gone
to the cross sex hormone treatment when
you eliminate that variable you see that
a male to female transgender the brain
size is exactly in line with other males
and it only changes once you go through
cross hormone across sexual hormone
replacement therapy now there's a big
controversy right now in the medical
community just regarding testosterone
replacement therapy or growth hormone
for injuries some people think that's a
problem going into estrogen putting it
directly into a male which every every
study we have which show bad results
cancerous results is it not within the
bounds of reason for a doctor or an
establishment like Johns Hopkins who
maybe they're not ignorant maybe some of
them are progressive liberals and they
just say these are not great results
we've studied it we don't want to do
this right now we need to wait until the
science isn't is that a possibility I
mean I'm not familiar with the studies
that you've talked about I'm familiar
with studies that show that there are no
consequences for for trans people that
use cross hormone therapy and I'm
familiar with many studies that show
that there are great benefits to their
health and well-being
right here transsexuals had brain
volumes in agreement with their sex at
birth intracranial volume and thalamus
felling of males were larger than
females irresponsive condition of
transsexualism this supports the notion
of the brain volume changes and
transsexuals are related to cross sex
hormone treatment and do not reflect
pre-existent differences in brain volume
between transsexuals and comparisons so
isn't that isn't it possible for a
doctor to
this comes from medical journals to say
well we know the changes occur after the
sex hormone replacement therapy and we
know that that can be bad so let's hold
off or is that doctor ignorant cuz I
want to make sure we frame in the
language because there are a lot of
doctors out there who would probably
agree with you except for when it comes
to the medicine I mean that's not the
mainstream understanding whatsoever you
have one study that has to actually no
it's not what the American Medical
Association says it's not what the
American Psychiatric Association says
you have one doctor Paul McHugh at Johns
Hopkins who has many anti-lgbt biases
you talk about doctors now he's gone
from absorbing some what's mainstream
you said I've not seen those so we've
provided you with empirical data studies
you say well I've not seen that and then
you go to some doctors say this and we
could both agree right there's there's a
political motivation behind a ton of
what happens in the medical industry I'm
sure we're on board with that probably
with big pharmaceuticals probably with
medical boards we'd agree on that when
it comes to a lot of things so now we've
denied the data and the statistics that
one doctor said with medical
organizations actually using I'm only
familiar with one doctor who advocates
against cross hormone therapy and
transitioning for for trans people and
that's Paul McHugh at Johns Hopkins and
that's what Johns Hopkins gets that
reputation so I'm not familiar with the
study that you cited I'm not I'm not
sure I understand what it is your
concluding from that study except
something about how brains change but
what I know is differences I've not
included something don't say I only know
one doctor that's not accurate Zack
there's more than one doctor on planet
earth who thinks that injecting estrogen
into a man or abnormal levels of
testosterone into a woman could be bad
the only point I'm making here is that
doesn't mean that this sector of the
medical industry or America or the world
means they're bigoted or ignorant you're
drawing a conclusion I'm not I'm saying
is it within the bounds of reason that a
doctor may not want to treat that
because the science isn't in and it
doesn't necessarily make them a
transphobic bigot it's a simple question
there's two pieces of that okay one is
I'm highly suspicious of any doctor that
draws their own conclusions based on
things that they can find in certain
studies
the rest of the industry has found other
a different approaches isn't necessary
if everyone agrees in select psychiatric
community or at least an overwhelming
majority and everyone agrees in the
medical community that the best way to
help trans people achieve wellness is to
support them in the transitions that and
it doesn't matter to me if there's a
couple doctors who disagree that's just
not accurate Zack we can have an honest
come but that's not accurate you can't
come on and say that and say there might
be a couple doctors it's not accurate
it's not honest to say they're not
entirely unanimous and even if that were
the case consensus is an agreement
because they were they were unanimous
that it was a disorder not long ago why
is that not okay because it's changed
that's how science works we learn more
and we do what makes the most sense
based on the evidence that comes in
removed is because we've got more have
but instead supporting trans people in
their transition is what supports their
well-being
you just discount the evidence today I
brought up and said I've not heard of it
and I only know of one doctor that's not
science but what I'm saying is that that
does not represent the consensus you
find in an exception to the rule does
not just if a doctor says I want to get
back the question because you're getting
out if a doctor because you said denied
healthcare and you use this and you call
people bigots and you call them ignorant
if a doctor who is treating someone and
still will treat that person as any
other patient but says I'm not going to
do hormone replacement therapy or go
down that path but I will treat you as a
patient are you filing that under
denying health care I just want to be
clear if the standards of health care
say that supporting trans people in
their transition is the best way to
support them and they are rejecting
those standards we do have them and
those are the standards that they reject
then yet I would say that there's
there's a problem that that's denial
treatment okay I just want to make clear
for the audience listening because when
when Zack Ford says transgender people
are being denied treatment and record
numbers what he is saying is if every
single doctor does not give them any
kind of transition treatment they want
that should be considered denial of
health care and the same token I can't
get a lot of treatments that I want that
are electable for my doctor so I just I
just want to make sure people understand
that thinking about them well you just
threw the word elective out
is that it's not a lactam problem is
that we know from the research that
supporting trans people in transition is
what supports their mental health
wellness and so if they're not if that
you know the experiencing gender
dysphoria if they're experiencing any
sort of depression or suicidal thinking
as a result of not being able to correct
that just phoria then rejecting them the
treatment that helps them overcome that
is problematic oh gosh we use that word
problematic well the suicide rates don't
get much better they do it because
you're using the Swedish study that
doesn't actually say what everybody says
it was I know dr. Boniface used it on
your show last week and if you look at
the Swedish study it did find that there
were high rates of suicide among people
who had had surgery but it didn't
compare character to them against other
transgender people the researcher of
that study has publicly said that to use
her research to suggest that suicide
rates go up after surgery you know no I
didn't say suicide rates went out I did
not say I didn't say suicide rates went
up I said suicide rates don't get much
better and the suicide rates if you look
at after surgery is still astronomically
much higher than the general populace or
gay Americans right right with surgery
that has to do with the discrimination
the experience I mean what it may be
have to do with you said that again
you're stating some we gotta stay on
task you're Zack with when you state a
fact we need it
okay let's define it you say the
discrimination so do you believe that
transsexuals transgender the the term
abusing it gets now to be more umbrella
you believe they faced worse
discrimination than black American
slaves people in the Holocaust what
about black people in the 60s who didn't
have the right to vote what about gay
Americans in the 80s you believe that
they're treated multiple times worse
because their suicide rates are worse
than black American slaves it doesn't
matter how any of those other groups are
treated what matters it doesn't matter
because you said it's a result of
discrimination but now when we eliminate
okay here other groups who are clearly
much more violently discriminated
against than transgenders nowhere near
anywhere else on the map that kind of a
suicide rate whether it's pre or post
surgery the only other place you find
that would be people with severe
psychiatric conditions but the research
that we have shows that the people with
the highest tendency to attempt suicide
are those who have experienced the
highest rates of discrimination and the
highest rates of family rejection so you
can think whatever you want I'm not
trying to compare them to any other
group I'm simply saying that the
research we have shows that it's not
surgery that impacts their or suicide
rate at one point or one way or the
other it's kind of experience that they
have in society where they can't get
jobs they can't find housing and of
course there's going to be consequences
to come with that okay so the suicide
rate does isn't impacted by surgery one
way or the other I just want to make
sure you just said that I'm saying that
theá--
does we agree on that does not make it
worse yeah it doesn't make it worse but
it doesn't make it better
is that a fair middle ground no I don't
think that's true either because I think
that the research shows that having
surgery and going through transition
actually helps to improve their wellness
that's what the researcher you just said
the opposite doesn't affect it one way
or the other okay let's go with that
let's assume that it's minut and even
after it can we agree on this middle
ground even after surgery the suicide
rate is still astronomically higher than
these other groups who face
discrimination that I just named yes
that fair it's certainly higher than the
general public and then others who've
been discriminated against whether
they're gay I don't have data about what
the suicide rate was among slaves
hundred years black Americans in a six
month the suicide rate okay well I just
want to make sure we can find I'm trying
to find some middle ground there and it
kind of going back and forth so I just
wanna make sure there's no way for a
doctor in any case anyone in the medical
community doctor who sees the issue as
anything other than full transition
surgery hormone replacement therapy
science is in without being the nine
care or transphobic correct well I would
qualify that only to say that different
patients have different needs but yes
there are standards of care for trans
people and if the doctor doesn't follow
them then they're denying them the care
that this is important just for people
listening one thing I do fight so you
are and and we wanted to have Chad Felix
green on and we wanted to respect your
wishes because you and him have gone
back and forth on Twitter I know you
didn't want to something that I feel
like everyone should agree on so no one
has given me a convincing argument here
and I'm willing to hear it maybe you can
because I know you've made this a big
part of your platform if you're against
exposure laws disclosure laws for those
who's listening if someone has HIV basic
laws that say if you have HIV AIDS you
need to disclose it to a partner before
you have
sex otherwise you should be liable
you're against that let me hear the
mincing argument as to why well let me
let me ask the question at least
rhetorically of why having the law is
good the laws that we have on the books
criminalizing the transmission of HIV
without disclosure date back to very
early in the epidemic when we didn't
know as much about it and what we now
know is that those laws actually hurt
our efforts to stop the epidemic so the
question is do you want to actually
minimize how much HIV is spread or do
you want this sort of petty feeling of
justice against people who already have
HIV and have to struggle with that
interesting you should bring up epidemic
or petty struggle epidemic give me
numbers aids at its highest the United
States
I mean it's continues to be high I don't
have all those numbers at the ready mark
I don't have them at the ready I'm not
gonna cancer accountable the diabetes
epidemic coverable deburred they're not
they're not hits they're not it's still
a problem now the epidemic hasn't end or
not they've never been high how high are
they outside of the gay community I see
they're high in the gay community
outside of the gay community what are
the chances of contract what are the
numbers outside of the gay community of
someone getting AIDS I just want said
epidemic epidemic is something that is
measurable it should or pandemic if you
want to go further with SARS at the
Toronto Airport I remember they were
throwing that around Canada was the only
country to still get SARS we screwed
that one up Canada you say epidemic you
need to substantiate that
my use of the word epidemic means that
it's continually spreading not that it's
representative of any sort of numbers I
don't really care who's vulnerable to it
who is it there are a lot of people
still getting it and that's a problem
okay
well it's almost an it's an entirely
preventable disease in the United States
it sure is
right particularly with disclosure laws
no those aren't happen at all
what they don't help at all no what
helps is if people get tested and if
they test positive if they get on
treatment so that they can reduce their
viral load kind of detectable levels
that makes it nearly impossible for them
to transmit the virus nearly I'm deaf
now it's never happened with people
having undetectable viral that's
transmitting the virus it's virtually
impossible I would say materially or
virtually if it's impossible because
just because science hasn't found an
example of a happening doesn't mean it
can't happen but the resources
disclosure law doesn't be very hard to
know what someone's viral load was you
and I both know that right if someone's
not disclosed you can't possibly know
what kind of treatment are there where
their viral load is or where you're
getting the HIV but the problem Stephan
is that the disclosure laws actually
scare people out of getting tested and
so there are a lot of people who don't
know their status and one of the reason
this is kind of they're afraid if they
know other status and they're positive
then they're opening themselves up to
liability so the disclosure laws are
actually discouraging people from
finding out their status and
discouraging people from getting tested
and then discouraging people from
getting so we've got so what about the
right of the person what about the right
of the person who's having sex with
another man who doesn't want to get HIV
or AIDS I'm still not hearing why it's
not that person's right to know for it
to be disclosed again I'm just trying
here this and charter schools school
choice are two issues on which I've
never heard a convincing argument so I
want to give you one last pass because
that one didn't cut the mustard well
there certainly I'm not gonna disagree
that share your status is proper
etiquette but the issue is whether or
not it becomes a legal issue and where I
stand is what about the responsibility
of the person to ask the question you
know if a person lies about their status
when they're asked about it that's very
different than simply not disclosing
because if a person is you know using a
condom and they're undetectable like
they're not posing a risk to the other
person's why are you imposing a criminal
liability on them it's just stigmatized
and as long as as long as that is not
entirely 100% impossible if there's a
chance of you giving a potentially
life-threatening virus disease to
somebody you should disclose that that
person has a right to know well one it's
not life-threatening anymore so what are
the death rates then my point is right
this is one of the single most funded
diseases out there if you're gonna say
epidemic what are the numbers and what
are the death rates if you're saying
it's really not that common it's
entirely preventable and it's not deadly
why are we going around screaming it's
an epidemic I'm saying that it's still
very commonly spread I'm saying that but
it's not and we know it's not
don't wanna bring up the numbers that's
why aids is always brought up as a
percentage in not actual numbers it is
miniscule
it is incredibly unlikely but what I'm
sayin submission rates have not gone
down so you can quibble about how many
people are affected by it that's fine
but the transmission rates have not gone
down so that the size of the problem has
not gone down and yes we've improved
treatment that's helping people do
better but it's not necessarily changing
the fact that we need to get them on
treatment so that they don't have the
problems that people used to have when
we do so why do you apply personal
responsibility to the person who may be
infected with HIV to ask but you don't
apply the personal responsibility to
simply go get their checkups and get
treated why is one responsible for
someone else disclosing and that one
person isn't responsible for his own
sexual misconduct I think we're all
responsible for ourselves and the
decisions that we make with our bodies
where I have the problem is where we
pass a law that criminalizes people in a
way that doesn't actually help in the
dozen criminalize people because you've
written then have it up on my screen
laws that criminalize HIV you wrote in
33 states just to be clear HIV is not
criminalized in any state it is having
sex with someone when you have HIV and
not telling them that is the illegal act
so I just want make sure we define the
language because I think that's the only
way we can have these honest
conversations if you like this clip it's
taken from the full-length podcast every
week you can click that box down below
to watch the full free video cast or
subscribe on iTunes to watch them the go
click my face to go to latter with
better calm where we write plenty of
articles columns and upset those who are
easily triggered or click below me
there's some other video down there I
don't know what it is yet not gay Jarrod
is going to toss it's probably going to
be something ambiguous but uncomfortable